hello everyone
welcome to simply learns youtube channel
today we will be discussing
java interview questions we all know
that java is one of the most
sought programming languages in the
current id industry there are multiple
multi-million dollar companies which are
using java
till today so this video is completely
dedicated to help out the java
developers and the beginners in java
programming language
to crack the most frequently asked java
interview questions
so without further ado let's begin with
our interview questions
at first we will start with the beginner
level interview questions
so in the beginner level interview
questions the first question we have is
what is jit
so the answer for this question is
jit is an abbreviation for java in
time compiler it increases efficiency
of the interpreter by compiling the
bytecode in the runtime
or just in time compiler compiles code
to machine level directly
for higher speeds of code execution so
basically just in time compilation is a
feature
added to the interpreter of java so this
involves conversion of the
code directly to machine level during
the compilation stage
this improvises the speed of execution
of a java program
now after the first question the second
question in the docket is
what is a class loader now let's discuss
the answer for this particular question
so basically class loader is the first
file to load when you execute
any java program so the java class
loader is the integrated part of java
virtual machine
so the functionality of class loader is
to load the class to the java virtual
machine
while it is demanded to execute a class
java has both strap extension and
application type of class loaders
so the third question in the docket is
what are the memory allocations
available in java
so the answer for this particular
question is java provides
multiple types of memory allocations but
the five major types of memory
allocations which are most frequently
used are
class memory heap memory stack memory
program counter memory native method
stack memory
so the next question in the list is
will the program run if i write static
public void main so basically we write
public static word main but in case
imagine if i write the program as static
public void main
will the program execute properly so the
answer for this question
is yes because java does not follow any
specific rule for the order of
specifiers you place in your program
so when you execute the program with
such pattern in your specifiers
then the program will compile
successfully also
it will run successfully so the next
question we have is
what is the default value stored in
local variables
so in c programming language when you
declare
a local variable or a global variable or
any type of variable
then the first value which is stored
inside that variable will be a
garbage value unless you initialize the
variable with a personalized value
for example if you declare a variable i
equal to 0 then you are storing a value
in that
variable i that is 0. if you just
declare it as
int i then the value stored inside that
i variable will be a garbage value
so similarly when you declare some kind
of local variable
in java then what will be the default
value stored inside it
so the answer for this question is
neither the local variables
or the global variables or any
primitives or any object references do
not have
any kind of default value stored in them
so followed by the fifth question we
have the sixth question
so what would be the output of the
following code segment
is the sixth question so this might
happen sometimes
so basically what happens is your
interviewer will throw a question at you
which has a code segment so all you need
to do is
decode that code in your mind and
provide the output
so this would be the code that we will
be dealing with
so you can see our question has
two printf statements the first one has
100
plus 100 plus a string which is simply
learn
and in the second printf statement we
have a string that is
e-learning company plus 100 plus 100.
so what will be the output of these two
printf statements
so the answer for this question is
really simple
so we'll be having 200 simply learn
as the first output and e-learning
company
one zero zero one zero zero as the
second output
why let's check out the code segment
once again
so when you see the code segment once
again so the first printf statement has
100 plus 100 plus simply learn so
jvm here understands 100 as an integer
value
and the plus symbol as an addition
operator here
so followed by the addition operator we
have another integer value
so what jvm does is it adds the two
numbers
hundred plus hundred so followed by that
we have another
plus symbol here so followed by the plus
symbol we have a string value
so here the jvm considers the plus
symbol
as a concatenating operator
but not as an addition operator so
that's why the first two numbers got
added and the result was 200
and the next two values were
concatenated
so it became as 200 simply learn
similarly
in the second printf statement the jvm
encountered
with a string value so it considered the
plus
symbol as a concatenating operator
similarly
it happened with the second plus symbol
as well
so that's the reason we had e-learning
one zero zero one zero zero as the
second output
now followed by the sixth question we
have the seventh question
what is an association so the answer for
this question
is an association can be defined as a
relationship
that has no ownership over the other so
to understand this definition
we can consider a simple example
consider a person associated with
multiple banks
so consider person x who has got
accounts
in bank a bank b and bank c and
similarly a bank is associated with
person x
that is a bank a bank b and banksy are
associated with the person x
but no one has ownership over the other
a person x
who is an account holder with all the
three banks that is a
b and c does not possess any kind of
ownership over the
three banks similarly banks
a b and c who has the customer
which is the person x but the banks do
not possess
any kind of ownership over the customer
so the relationship between the person x
and the banks abc can be considered
as an association now followed by the
seventh question
we have the next question that is the
eighth question
define copy constructor and java
so the answer for this question is as
follows
a copy constructor in java is a
constructor
that initializes an object through
another object of the same class
a copy constructor in java is really
helpful
because when you want to copy a complex
object that has several fields
or when we want to make a deep copy of
an existing object
then the copy constructor is the one
which will help you out in this
situation
so followed by the eighth question we
have the ninth question
what is a marker interface
so the answer for this question is
an empty interface in java is referred
as
a marker interface serializable and
cloneable are some of the popular
examples of marker interface
so basically a marker interface is just
another interface
but normally in interface we provide
some
signatures so these signatures belong to
particular methods
so in normal interface we just have
method signatures
but not the complete implementation or
at least we'll be having some variables
but in a marker interface we do not have
any kind of data manipulating
method signatures any data members
nothing
they have special functionality unlike a
normal interface
so followed by the ninth question we
have the tenth question
what is object cloning i guess the word
object learning is completely
self-explanatory
yet the answer for this question is it
is an ability to recreate an
object completely similar to the
existing object
this process is known as object cloning
in java
java provides a built-in function or
method that is the clone method
to clone an existing object offering the
same functionality that of the original
object
so followed by the 10th question we have
our 11th question
why is java not completely object
oriented
so this question might be a little
confusing but it's true java is not
completely object oriented
but what's the reason yes i'll explain
you why
java is not completely object oriented
so the answer for this question is
java is not considered as 100
object-oriented programming language
because of the data types it uses it
still makes use of
eight or more primitive data types which
are end
flow double and few others so this is
the only reason why
java is not considered as completely 100
object oriented programming language so
the next question
is define wrapper classes in java
so the answer for this question is in
java
when you declare primitive data types
that is the endfloat double etc
then the wrapper classes are responsible
for converting them into
objects or reference types just as we
discussed before
java is not 100 object oriented
programming language
just because of the primitive data types
it uses so when you
include such primitive data types then
wrapper classes are the ones
which convert them into objects or
reference types
for the ease of compilation and
execution of programs
without any issues so followed by this
question
we have the next question define
singleton classes
in java so the answer for this question
is in java
when you make the constructor of a class
as private then the particular class can
generate only
one single object this is the reason why
such type of classes are called as
singleton classes so followed by that we
have our next
question that says define package in
java
so if you use some of the popular ides
that is the integrated development
enterprises
such as intellij or eclipse then you
might be familiar
with projects packages source files and
then
the class file so basically you create a
project
first and inside the project you will be
having your source folder
and then you will be creating your own
package using the source folder
and inside the package you will create a
class file
and inside the class file is where you
write your java program
so here the question is define package
in java so the answer for this question
is as follows
package is a collective bundle of
classes and interfaces
along with necessary libraries and jar
files
the use of packages helps in code
reusability so basically when you create
a specific
package inside that package you will
store all the class files that you will
be using
in your java program so not only class
files
in case if you use any kind of
connectors
or any kind of jar files or any kind of
dependencies for your java program
you will include all those inside the
package so that
the requirements and the class files are
bundled together
and this helps out in code reusability
making sure that the program files or
the java files or any dependencies are
not juggling between
one package to the other or one file to
the other
so using a package is basically a good
practice
so followed by this we have our next
question
can you implement pointers in java
program
so if you remember c programming
language
we had pointers there so we use pointers
to
directly access the memory
so similarly can you use pointers in a
java program
this is a little tricky question for
beginners
but basically it's really simple now the
answer for this question is
no because java virtual machine
personally takes care of memory
management
implicitly so java's major motive was to
keep programming
simple so accessing memory directly
through pointers is
not a recommended action so the answer
is a big
no you cannot implement pointers in java
program
so followed by that we have our next
question
differentiate between instance and local
variables
so the answer for this question is
really simple instance variables are
declared inside a class and the scope
is limited to only a specific object
inside which
an instance variable is created so
followed by the instance variable
we have the local variable so the local
variable can be anywhere inside a method
or
a specific block of code also the scope
is limited to the block of code
where the variable that is the local
variable is declared
now followed by the 16th question we
have our next
question explain java
string pool so the answer for this
question is
a collection of strings in java's heap
memory
is referred as java's string pool
so for example you wanted to create a
new string
consider your name so your name might be
some xyz
so if you wanted to create xyz string
then you
provide that particular code to your jvm
so what does jvm do
it will not directly create that
particular string first
it will search for the xyz string
in your string pool if that is already
existing in your string pool
then it will provide a reference to that
particular string
in case if xyz is not there
then the jvm will create a new string
that is the
xyz string so followed by this we have
our next question that is
what is an exception so the answer for
this question
is an exception in java is considered as
an unexpected event
that can disrupt the normal flow of the
program
so for example just consider that you
are
going to write a program for division
operator
so after you finish your program your
evaluator
might want to test your code to the
extreme levels so instead of providing
a proper number imagine that your
evaluator is providing a
wrong input such as special symbols
sometimes 0 or any other sort of input
so if this kind of input is provided to
your program
then your program might crash so you can
avoid this kind of crash by using
exception handling
so basically you can use try and catch
blocks
so you can embed your code inside the
try block
and say to your program that if any kind
of wrong input such as
special symbol or 0 is provided by the
evaluator then send a message saying
wrong input or divide by zero exception
so this kind of approach will provide an
output
but this kind of approach will avoid
your program from crashing
so this is how exceptions are handled in
real time
so followed by this we have our next
question
what is final keyword in java
so the answer for this question is the
term final
is a predefined word in java that is
used while declaring values to variables
when a value is declared using the final
keyword
then that particular value of that
particular
variable will remain constant throughout
the execution of program
so sometimes if you include a normal
variable
and provide an operation on that
particular variable
then the value of that particular
variable will change after the execution
of program
but when you declare the same variable
using final keyword
then no number of operations or any kind
of manipulations applied onto that
variable will
not change the value of that particular
variable
so that's the speciality of final
keyword in java
so followed by that we'll dive into the
next question that is
what happens when the main method is not
declared as
static so the answer for this question
is
when the main method is not declared a
static then the program
may be compiled perfectly but ends up
with a serious ambiguity
and throws a runtime error that says
no such method error so when you
basically declare a main method
don't forget to specify the static
keyword
so with this we finish the beginner
segment of questions
followed by the beginners segment we
have the next
segment that is the intermediate level
segment
so the first question in the
intermediate level is
what is jdk and mention the variance of
jdk so the answer for this question is
so jdk is basically an abbreviation for
java development kit
this is a combined package of jre that
is the java runtime environment
and developer tools used for designing
java applications and
applets oracle has the following
variants for
java development kit so the first one is
the
jdk standard edition which is normally
used by
beginners and intermediate developers
next after the jdk standard edition we
have the java development kit
for enterprise so this particular
enterprise edition
is used by professional java developers
for developing
java based applications and frameworks
now the last one is the java development
kit
micro edition now followed by 21st
question
we will dive into the next question that
says
brief access specifiers and types of
access specifiers
in java so the answer for this question
is as follows
basically access specifiers are
predefined keywords used to help a java
virtual machine
to understand the scope of a particular
data member
or data manipulating method within a
class or outside the class
so in java we have four types of access
specifiers
the first one is public access specifier
so when you declare a data member or a
data manipulating method
as public then that particular data
member or
method can be accessible by any class or
object throughout the package followed
by that
we have the private access specifier so
unlike the public access specifier when
you provide the
private access specifier then the
accessibility of that particular
private data member or the data
manipulating method
will be provided to specific classes and
specific
objects only and finally we have the
protected access specifier
so the protected access specifier is a
bit
more secure than the private access
specifier so the access for this
particular protected data member or
protected data manipulating method could
be a little more
difficult to access unless you are going
to implement
everything which is present in that
particular package
so basically if you are trying to access
the protected data member or protected
data manipulating method
of a different package then you need to
first import the
package into your existing package
so that's how the protected access
specifier works practically
so finally after the major three axis
specifiers we have the default access
specifier
so default access specifier will be
provided by the java virtual machine
so in case if you declare a variable
or a data manipulating method without
using any specific access specifiers
that are public private and protected
then jvm implicitly considers
the default access specifier so there is
no much of a difference between the
public access specifier and the default
access specifier
both have the same functionality and
accessibility
so followed by this question we enter
into the next question
that is can a constructor return a value
so the answer for this question is as
follows yes
a constructor can written a value it
basically returns the current instance
of a class
implicitly he cannot make a constructor
written a value explicitly
but automatically it returns
the instance of a class so the next
question is
explain this keyword in java so in java
we do have a keyword
which is called as this so what does
the keyword this mean in java is a
question
so the answer for this question is the
term this is a special keyword
designated as a reference variable
so the term this keyword is used to
refer to the current class properties
like data manipulating method instance
data member and constructors so followed
by the 24th question we have our next
question that says explain
super keyword in java so the answer for
this question is
as follows the term super is a special
keyboard designated as a reference
variable so similar to
this keyword even super keyword acts
as a reference variable but the
difference is
super keyword is used to refer to the
immediate parent class
object so followed by the 25th question
we have our next question
that is explain method overloading in
java
so basically method overloading and
method overriding etc are the concepts
of polymorphism
so now let's have a correct answer here
so the process of creating multiple
method signatures
using one method name is called as
method overloading
so for example consider that you wanted
to include an addition operation in your
program
that performs addition operation so
the first method will be having the name
add
and inside the method parameters you
will be having
two integer types of parameters
similarly
you wanted to perform another addition
operation
with the same name at so here you will
provide the method name
completely same to the first method but
inside the parameters there is a
difference
you are adding three parameters here
so when you pass the values to the add
method
then which method to be overloaded
that's the confusion right
so should i overload or should i execute
the first add method or the second
method so this completely depends on the
number of parameters you pass
if you are passing two parameters then
the first method will be executed
if you are passing three parameters then
the second method will be executed
so this is how the method overloading
happens in java
so the process of method overloading can
be
achieved by using two different ways the
first way is to
change the number of arguments so that's
what exactly i've discussed before
now the second way is varying the
written type of the method
so with this let's enter into the next
question
can we overload a static method
so as discussed before the values
of the variables or data manipulating
methods will
not be changed when we have used the
keyword static in front of it
so the question is can we overload a
static method
now let's discuss the answer for this
the answer is
no java does not support overloading of
static method the process worked through
an error
reading static method cannot be
referenced
so followed by this we have our next
question
so the next question is define late
binding the answer for this question is
binding is a process of unifying the
method call with the methods code
segment
late binding happens when the methods
code segment is unknown
till the method is called during the
runtime
so followed by this we have our next
question
define dynamic method dispatch
so the answer is the dynamic method
dispatch is a process
where the method call is executed during
the runtime
the overridden method is called through
a reference variable of
superclass so this process is called as
runtime polymorphism now we have our
next
question why is delete function
faster in linkedlist than an array
so basically linked list and array
are the java collections or in other
words it's also considered as
data structure so to answer this
question you need to understand the
analogy of linked list and array
so basically an array is um complete
memory block of consecutive memory
locations
so consider that your memory location
starts from 100
and your array has 10 locations so
it's a complete reserve block of from
100 101 102 to 1.9
so you have 10 memory blocks so in case
if you wanted to add a number
or a delete a number then you had to
make changes
to the complete memory block but when
you come into
linked list you have the memory blocks
used from the memory heap so basically
what you do here is
you basically connect the nodes through
addresses
so in case if you wanted to eliminate a
number then
what you do is just to manipulate the
addresses
so the address of the consecutive node
will be changed
so that's the only change what you make
so now
this is the reason why the delete
function or any kind of
manipulation function is faster in
linked list compared to array
so now let's have a brief answer on this
delete function is faster in linked list
as the user needs to make
a minor update to the point of value so
that the
node can point to the next successor in
the list
now followed by this we have our next
question
give a briefing on the life cycle of a
thread
so the life cycle of a thread includes
five stages which are as mentioned below
newly born state runnable state that is
it provides the jvm with a feedback that
i'm ready to run now
followed by that the running stage where
the threat is
actually running followed by that the
block stage
so basically the thread will be blocked
for some reasons for some intermediate
output or something
if the thread is waiting for an input
from another source or
something similar so that's where the
blocked state comes to existence
and finally the dead state once after
everything is
processed the threat is eliminated by
gvm
now followed by this we have our next
question that says
explain the differences between the
operators provided here
so the operators might look similar but
they are different
now let's understand about these
operators in a much better way
through the answer so the answer for
this question is
although they look similar but there's a
huge difference between them
so the first operator which looks like
two greater than symbols
perform the operation of right shifting
so when you provide
a binary number or binary value then the
bits will be shifted towards the right
and the second symbol or the second
operator which is having
three greater than symbols is used to
shift out the zero
filled bits so this is the functionality
of these two operators
now followed by that let's have the 33rd
question
brief the life cycle of an applet
so the answer for this question is the
life cycle of an applet basically
involves the following stages
the first stage is the initialization
stage next
is the start stage third is the stop
stage
fourth is destroy and finally we have
paint
now the next question is why are
generics
used in java so the answer for this
question
is compile time type safety is provided
by using generics in java
so this approach allows the users to
catch unnecessary
invalid inputs at the time of
compilation
generic methods and classes help
programmers to specify
a single method declaration a set of
related methods or
with a single class declaration a set of
related types
so followed by this we have our next
question
explain externalizable interface
so the answer for this question is the
externalizable interface helps with the
control over the process of
serialization the externalization
interface
incorporates read external and right
external methods
so we have listened to a new term here
which is serialization
so what exactly is serialization
serialization is a process of
sending your java code or java project
from one computer system to a different
computer system
so basically if you wanted to execute
some kind of java program
from a different location then you
serialize this particular code to a
different location where you actually
want to execute
and this particular process of
transferring your code
is called as serialization now the next
question is explain daemon thread
so the answer for this question is the
daemon thread can be defined as a thread
with
least responsibility the daemon thread
is designed to run
in a background during the process of
garbage collection in java
the set daemon method is used to create
the demon thread in java programming
language
so we have our next question now explain
the term enumeration in
java so the answer for this question is
enumeration or enum is an interface in
java
enum allows the sequential access of
elements stored in a collection
in java now the next question is
why is java considered as a dynamic
programming language
so the answer for this question is java
was designed to adapt to an evolving
environment
java programs include large amount of
runtime information that is actually
used to resolve
access to the objects in real time so
this is a reason why java is considered
as
dynamic programming language now
followed by this we have our next
question can you run a code before
executing the main method
so the answer for this question is yes
we can execute any code even before the
main method
we will be using the static block of
code in the class
when creating the objects at load time
of the class
any statements within the static block
of the code will execute it
once while loading the class even before
the creation of objects in the main
method
now the last question in the
intermediate section is
how many times the finalized method is
called
so the answer for this question is the
finalized method
is called by the garbage collector so
for every object the garbage collector
calls the finalized method
just for once
now with this let's enter the advanced
segment of interview questions based on
java so the first question
in the advanced segment is can the
keywords
this and super we used
together so the answer for this question
is
no this and super keywords should be
used in the first statement in the class
constructor
so the following code segment will give
you a better idea
so you can see that we have used the
keyword super
and this in the class constructor that
is the first class constructor
now this is how you can use super
keyword and this keyword together in
case if you wanted to use
so with this let's continue with the
next question in the advanced level
so the next question says explain jsp
page so the answer for this question is
jsp is basically an
abbreviation for java servlet page so
the java servlet page consists of
two types of text the first is the
static data
and the second one is java servlet page
elements
now the next question is explain
jd bc so the answer is jdbc is an
abbreviation for java database connector
jdbc is an abstract layer used to
establish connectivity between
any existing database and to a java
application next question is
explain the various directives of jsp
so the directives are instructions
processed by jsp
engine after the jsp page is compiled
into a servlet
directives are used to set page level
instructions
insert data from external files and
specify
custom tag libraries directives are
defined between
the following symbols so these are the
symbols that are used to specify the
directives
in a jsp page the different types of
directives are shown as below
there are three types of directives they
are include directive page directive
and tag lab directive so include
directive includes a
file and merges the content of the file
with the current page
the page directive is used to define
specific attributes in the jsp page
like error page and buffer the taglib
directory is used
to declare a custom tag library which is
used in the
jsp page followed by that we have the
next
question what are
observer and observable classes
so the answer for this question is
objects that subclass the observable
class
maintain a list of observers when an
observable object is updated
it invokes the update method of each of
the observers
to notify that the observers that it has
changed its
state the observer interface is
implemented by
objects that observe observable objects
might be a little confusing but you need
to read this answer once again
you can pause it and you can read this
answer once again so that you can get a
brief understanding of this
followed by that we have the next
question what is
session management in java so the answer
for this question is
a session is essentially defined as the
dynamic stage of a random conversation
between
the client and the server the essential
communication channel includes the
string of responses
and requests from both sides typically
the most popular way of implementing
session management is the employment of
a session id in the communicative
discourse of the client and the server
the next question is brief about spring
framework spring framework is basically
the framework of frameworks
now the answer for this question is
spring is essentially defined as the
application framework and inversion of
control container for java basically
the chief purpose of spring framework is
to create
enterprise applications in java also it
is
especially useful to keep in mind that
the central features of the spring
framework are essentially conductive
to any java application
so the next question is explain jca
in java so the answer for this question
is jca
is basically an abbreviation for java
cryptography
architecture so jca provides a platform
that gives architecture and apis for
encryption as well as decryption
jc is used by the developer to combine
the application with the security
measure
it also helps in performing the third
party security rules
it uses the hash table encryption
message digest etc
to implement the security so the next
question
is explain jpa
in java so the answer for this question
is jpa stands as an abbreviation for
java persistence api the jpa
is enabling us to create the persistence
layer for desktop
and web applications jpa deals with the
following
java persistence api query language
java persistence criteria api object
mapping metadata
etc so the last question in our list is
explain the different authentications in
java servlets
so the answer for this question is
authentication options available in
servlets are
as follows the first one is basic
authentication
so the basic authentication consists of
username and password provided by the
client
to authenticate as the user the second
one is
form based authentication in this
particular type of authentication
the login form is made by the programmer
by using
html followed by that
we have the third type of authentication
that is
digest authentication digest
authentication
is similar to basic authentication but
in this
the passwords are encrypted using hash
formula
this makes digest more secured and
lastly
we have the client certificate
authentication
the client certificate authentication
requires that each client
accessing the resource has a certificate
that it sends to authenticate
itself this requires ssl
protocol so with that we have come to an
end of this particular
tutorial based on java interview
questions
if you have any queries regarding the
interview questions session we had today
or if you feel that we have missed out
some important interview questions that
we were supposed to cover in this
particular tutorial
then please feel free to drop them down
in the comment section below
and we will have your questions answered
and also we will consider every
suggestion provided by you
so with that this is ravi signing off
until next time
thank you
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn it up and get certified
click here